we on the brink of a nuclear war we
could if because it's it's very
very you know Lebanon could come in
Syria can come in Egypt already has
350,000 troops staged to come in they're
threatening to Turkey cc is saying that
he's going to come
in and if that happens Russia will
almost certainly come in and we could
easily Sleepwalk into World War I and
you know the United States the people
are running our government now and
Anthony blinkin Jake Sullivan averil
Haynes uh Victoria Newan I don't think
any of them have a healthy fear of
nuclear war we also have a diminished
Armory and you know we're fighting a
two-front
war and it's going to be tempting to go
to the you know to the punchline to the
end game because uh you know we we're
not the Israeli Army is not equipped for
a very very big war like it was 10 years
ago they haven't been you know they've
been doing police actions they haven't
been new ring rail
fighting and those Arab countries are
now very very well armed it's not the
same countries that they were fighting
in you know ' 67 and uh 73 and all these
other you know uh Wars it's a very very
different countries that they're
fighting now so I'm very worried it I it
literally keeps me up late at
night
and I'm going to now bring in the the
real star of the show Dave Ruben thank
[Music]
you m switch mics all right we're
switching mics Make some noise for Bobby
everybody I have to say I uh fled
California very publicly about two years
ago I
campaign mic I campaign no there we go
I'm holding the antenna okay sorry it's
my first time doing this in front of an
audience
um I I fled California very publicly I
campaigned actually for the recall
alongside Larry Elder which obviously
did not end up going the way we might
have wanted here in Cali but I got
audited by the state 3 days after the
recall and that's actually the day that
I put my house for sale I mention that
only because this is one of the few
things that would bring me back to
California because I've I've soured on
this I now live in the Free State of
Florida but it's it's a pleasure
listening to you and my friend Dennis
Prager and I thought we'd start with
something a little a little bizarre
because obviously there's plenty to talk
about and and the world seems to be in a
bit of a chaotic place but on the way
here as I was in the car I looked at
your Twitter and I want to read your
last tweet because I think this
encapsulates a lot of people's
frustrations with what's going going on
here in California uh you wrote
yesterday an intruder climbed the fence
at my home and was arrested after being
released from police custody later in
the day he immediately returned to my
home and was arrested
again so twice in one day at your house
you mentioned that your wife charl was
doing a Facebook live stream at that
moment um is that a perfect example of
the frustrations that people are having
in this town in this State and and
really really across the country at this
point yeah I I was because you were with
me a few minutes ago when I learned that
that was up on my Twitter and I didn't
really want to put it up on on my
Twitter because I didn't want to seem
like I was whining but um my wife uh saw
him come over the fence when she was
doing a Twitter space with I mean a a
Facebook live uh or Instagram live um
and and then she saw these wonderful
guys from gav the back of the security
guys U with their guns drawn chasing him
and and putting U handcuffs on him but
he was got an intruder who had written
me over 400 emails um over the recent
months including many mening ones a uh a
week ago one that threatened to put a
bullet in my head um and so you know it
was a it's one of of several incidences
that happened recently
including a guy who showed up at um in
La at a uh at at a theater in Wilshire
where I was doing a rally and asked for
me and he was wearing a US Marshall
badge on a a lanyard badge and a um a
federal
it and he uh these guys spotted him
because they thought the badge was too
shiny and he asked to see
me and they uh they pulled him a side he
had two shoulder holsters on that were
fully loaded with uh each one with the
magazines loaded with eight bullets he
had a backpack on with another gun in it
loaded and he had I think four or five
extra magazines and KN knives and other
weapons in there and and his house later
on was filled with rifles and uh and he
gave it and he had given a Tik Tock
created a Tik Tok that said if I don't
come back from this um you know cont he
your commander and chief Etc so it was
um um you know we've repeatedly asked
the Biden Administration for Secret
Service protection I'm the only
candidate in
history who has asked for a presidential
candidate who has requested Secret
Service protection and been
denied um most people get you they
legally have to give it to you 120 days
out but it customarily is given my uncle
got it 500 Days out
uh cedy you know they they made secret
service available to candidates uh
before during the primaries after my
father was killed and ever since then
people are are just uh
proforma given I think Obama got it 500
Days out I'm now you know one 365 days
out so many many candidates have gotten
much earlier than me it's disturbing to
me because I'm watching the
politicization of the other law
enforcement
agencies and when my father got to the
justice department the first day the
justice department he called all the
attorneys together and the the one thing
he said to him is we are not going to do
we are not going to politicize Justice
in this
country and during my tenure at this
agency that there's going to be no
politization you know Democrats and
Republicans are going to be treated the
same and he gave that as an ironclad
order um President Biden has a statue of
my father behind
him um in the Oval Office and I but and
his family members at Secret Service
protection Anthony fouchy has a million
dollars of Secret Service protection um
a
month um you know and I people don't
like him so he you know he's entitled to
it John Bolton years after retiring as
Secret Service protection as do many
other
officials uh and it's it's politization
you know I I I imagine I don't know why
they're doing it exactly but I think
that they understand it's very very
expensive for me and that they'd rather
me be spending money on my protection
rather than you know on advertisements
or organization or field
organization uh so that's wrong now I I
want to say I just want to say this that
I'm involved in number of lawsuits
against the administration against the
government and
against one of those suits is now in
front of the Supreme Court Kennedy
versus Biden yes and um and that uh and
and it has a companion case Missouri
versus Biden we got a lower court
decision from Judge Dodie that's 155
pages long that decision is you know
Americans should have to read it in
civic's class because it shows what
happens when you politicize the law
enforcement agencies I it shows that
President Biden I was the first person
censored by the administration 37 hours
after he took the oath of office
President Biden of the White House was
ordering Twitter and Facebook and
Instagram to remove my accounts and
threatening them that if they did not do
so that they were going to the White
House was going to try to remove their
section 230 immunity which is
existential for them they could not they
they're companies would
die if they didn't have that section 230
immunity and what we found from the
Twitter files and from the from our
Discovery documents is that the white
house because of pressure from the White
House Facebook and the other social
media sites provided portals to the FBI
to go in directly and sensor material
and the FBI gave access to the
CIA the dhf
to the IRS and to about 12 other federal
agencies so you had you know listen I've
been censored for 18 years but not
officially by the
government and you know the New York
Times and CNN CNN won't put me on none
none of them will do that but they're
allowed to that's not that does not
violate the First Amendment if you own a
printing
press you can choose what to print and
what not to print if you own a uh t a
cable station you know you're not using
the airwaves but if you go on a cable
station you can decide what to censor
and not to censor when the
government begins telling you to censor
things now the first amendment is
implicated because that's exactly why we
passed the First Amendment to make sure
that the government could not silence
its critics and I and I'll say the last
thing
that a government think could silence
its critics has license for every
because uh you know if you can if you
can quiet criticism about yourself
there's no end to the power that you can
then
[Applause]
claim so I guess that's a great segue
you know I know a lot of people
obviously want to talk about what's
going on in Israel and we'll we'll get
to that but that's a great segue
to what has happened to the Democrat
Party you know the day that you
announced I said on my show and my
audience tends to lean a little more
conservative now I said to my Audience
by the end of this thing I don't know
that he will be a republican but he will
not be a Democrat and you are now
running independent and I I said it on
my show we'll we'll send you the clip I
said it the day you announced it was
obvious I had seen Dennis mentioned the
the why I left the left video that I did
I I've seen that path even just from
chatting to some of the people here this
evening they're on that path as well I
think a lot of people are waking up but
what do you think happened really to
that party that has led to the
radicalism Andor I would argue utter
incompetence that that we're seeing
right
now know I I think a couple of things
happened one is
um uh they you know the the Democratic
party was interesting because the
Democratic party I grew up in could not
I watched this Evolution happen because
I was involved in the medical Freedom
issues and it and that was really the
spear tip of what happened to the
Democratic party and the Democratic
party I grew up in always had trouble
fundraising because the the the the
groups that it could fund raise were
very limited they could fund raise from
trial
lawyers they could fund raise from
unions and but most of the big
corporations um were were off limits to
them you know a really pure Democrat
wouldn't take any corporate money which
meant you know it's hard to win
elections meanwhile the big money you
know um was going from the uh from the
oil industry the coal industry the
pesticide industry the big food Big Egg
industry was mainly going to Republicans
there were a lot of
Midwestern you know aate Democrats that
were taking money from Gill and Monsanto
and Smithfield and Purdue and Bo Pilgrim
Etc but on Democrats wouldn't take
pharmaceutical money
and then when in 2016 when they were
fighting when President Obama was
fighting over Obamacare or you know the
in the Years preceding 2016 2012 to
2016 the Democrats um they Obama
administration had to make a deal with
the pharmaceutical companies in order to
get uh in order to get ObamaCare through
because if the farm is the biggest Lobby
is on Capital and they could block it
they have more a they pay twice in
lobbying what the next biggest which is
oil and gas and about five times what
the military contractors pay so they're
they are off the charts and which and
how much they invest in
lobbying and the Obama administration
had to make a deal with them and the
deal they made is that we're going to do
Obamacare and we are going to buy you're
without bargaining we're going to we're
gonna buy everybody your drugs and
you're going to get really rich and uh
we won't barking for them we won't you
know push you down so they they got them
on
board at that point it became
permissible for Democrats to take
pharmaceutical money and they just
started taking it and then president
Trump ran in
2016 and president Trump said on three
occasions while he was
running at this time Democrats and
Republicans were evenly split over
vaccine safety so you could go and talk
to Democrats about it and president
Trump on three occasions said that he
believed that vaccines cause autism he
knew people who would who had mothers
and he told me this too three mothers
who had gotten uh whose kids had gotten
autism from vaccines so he said that and
Democrat that issue then became a tribal
issue Democrats put that issue in the
same dumpster the anti science dumpster
as climate denial and the other stuff
and it was just part of you know Trump's
Insanity so after that after 2016 you
could not talk about um about vaccines
to Democrats anymore and it became you
know it they they started def def they
started protecting the pharmaceutical
company and then we saw this complete
Insanity which people called Trump uh
Trump yeah Trump derangement
syndrome which is Donald Trump began
dictating the entire platform for the
Democratic party so the Democratic party
always hated
NAFTA and as soon as Trump said I don't
like NAFTA they started loving
it as soon you know Trump said I'm anti
war the Democrats Started Loving
war and you know and and it happened
with every issue it was extraordinary
it's like it's like the kid who hates
their parents and becomes their parent
because they hate them so much the
Democratic party became the you know the
very thing that you know the Tyrant and
the you know censor you know they they
were mad at at Trump for you know the
Republicans for censoring books and they
became the biggest censor in American
history so all this weird I mean that's
the evolution that I watch happen and I
think a lot of it now is just driven by
anything you know people are angry at me
the Democratic party because they say
it's dangerous they keep using that word
it's dangerous I've never heard anybody
say any Democrat
say we want President Biden because he
has a vision for this country and he has
the Vigor and energy to really lead this
country in this critical period nobody
ever says that they say you got to vote
for Biden or Trump will get in there so
it's all about using fear and you know
Democratic party the the by line of the
democratic party was Franklin D Ro
Roosevelt's warning that the only thing
we have to fear is fear itself the
reason he said that in 19 32 is cuz he
was watching what was happening in in
Europe with you know in Spain and Italy
and Germany where totalitarian systems
were emerging right-wing totalitarianism
and leftwing totalitarianism in in the
Soviet Union and and other states they
were all using fear to disable the
capacity for critical thinking to
disable the you know the affection and
affinity for
democracy and he said you know we can
get through this through this dep
economic
depression it's long as we don't
collapse in fear and we'll get through
it with our democracy intact with free
market capitalism intact and he was able
to save capitalism at that time about a
third of the people in this country
wanted Fascism and about a third wanted
communism and only a third wanted told
you know everybody thought the system
was broken and he was able to get
through that period
by calming us and saying don't give into
fear and that was you know the
Democratic party was not the party of
fear now it's the party of fear we saw
it during Co and we see it now in the
elections So speaking of those thirds
what is the Coalition look like to you
that you could put together that maybe
some of the other candidates can't
taking say the disaffected liberal I
suspect there's a bunch of them here uh
taking the more moderate conservative
like what what does that actually look
like what are the common points that
that could lead you to the White
House you know I think people ask me who
my constituency is and I always you know
say that it's uh it's the mgram
experiment constituency it's the 30% of
people who walked out of the Milgram
experiment which in the Milgram
experiment was the MK Ultra the CIA
experiment that was done at Yale that
where they were you know they brought
people into a room and they shocked them
you know the subjects were were told to
shot to turn a tile that would shock the
guy in the Next Room and that guy was a
confederate of Dr
mgram he was screaming and shouting and
struggling and pleading when they turned
it up and and Dr mgraham would say turn
it up turn it down turn it higher turn
it
down and the people were crying and
saying don't make me shock him again he
was wearing a you know a white uh lab
coat and a doctor all these increments
of of and vestages of of of the medical
Authority
and so they were doing what he said and
67% of them ended up putting it to 250
folds where it was marked potentially
lethal and so they were V and what mgram
concluded is they were that people when
when ordered to by
a a person of authority will violate
their most closely held
values and but the good re the good
result was that 33% of the people got up
and walked out and said I'm not doing
this and those were the people who who
did not have their crit their capacity
for critical thinking
disabled and I would say that would
include almost everybody in this
group that you know those are the people
who walked out of the mgram experiment
and I I think you know the last three
years was just this giant mgram
experiment where we had this guy you
know who was an authority we were told
trust the experts which by the way isn't
a thing right I mean it's definitely not
a feature of democracy it's not a
feature of of uh science it's a feature
of totalitarianism and and Orthodox Rel
religion trusting the EXP I mean I've
had
500 lawsuits all of them have involved
scientific controversy and every one of
them has experts on either side when I
sued
Monsanto I the Monsanto came with
experts from Harvard Yale and Sanford
and we had experts from Harvard Yale and
Sanford and they were saying exactly the
opposite thing about the same data so
you know experts you you can't trust the
experts in a
democracy you know one of the big Pains
of a democracy is that you actually
cannot you you have a duty to maintain a
posture of fear skepticism toward
anybody in Authority that is and
question
everything and um so I think the people
that are are you know are drawn to my
campaign are people who are disaffected
they're people who are questioning you
know everything and I think there's more
and more of those the Harvard Harris bll
that came out this week had me at
22% and what it what the people that are
are you know joining my campaign are
people who who watch long form
interviews Us in
podcast oh if you watch if the only
thing that you watch is CNN MSNBC and
read the New York Times you if I read
the that if I was in that information
bubble I would have a very low opinion
of
myself and so but what we find is and
that's mainly Democrats like hardcore
Democrats what we find is that when we
can get them to listen to a podcast that
within 10 minutes most of them convert
so they start rethinking so what you
know what I you know are if I can
maintain my polling numbers over 15%
they're going to have to let me into the
debates and I think I will do very well
in that
[Applause]
circumstance so let's talk about the the
thing that's obviously on everyone's
mind what's what's happening in Israel
uh but I thought maybe before we do the
macro sort of political version of that
we could maybe talk about how people are
feeling here in America because there
there clearly is a new level of fear and
you addressed fear earlier we're seeing
what's happening on the college campuses
we're seeing the radicalism within uh
the Democrat Party with h the the eight
members who I call the the Hamas caucus
um what what do you think is happening
here in America connected to to what's
going on in the Middle East and then we
can talk about it sort of politically
and geopolitically well I mean I think
there's this Insanity going on on the
campuses that you know was already
and what Dennis said in the left wing of
of the democratic party where there's um
you know there's this where they've just
adopted this false narrative about
Israel about the entire history of
Israel where people you know and I see
it and I'm shocked to see because I my
kids are very well educated and they um
and they I'd say most of their friends
are Jewish and even with their Jewish
friends there is this kind
of um there there's an ignorance about
you know the history of Israel and they
all atop this this uh narrative that
Israel is a white oppressor nation that
was dropped down on these you know
indigenous Palestinians and has been
dominating them and stealing
land and is an apar State it's engaged
in ethnic cleansing we all hear this
stuff and um and you know it's I you
know I think that one of my jobs is to
is to make the moral Case for Israel and
I think it's an easy case to
make um and you know I was talking in a
in a interview that in what we did in
the previous you know the YPO group that
was here before you guys there's um
there's a really good speech that was
done by Prince bandar which I urge you
all to get a hold of and it was done in
2020 and at that point you know Prince
bandar and I met I spent it yesterday I
think it was the day before yesterday I
spent the
day with Prince bandar's successor uh
Prince tur in Washington who is the
Saudi prince who took over as chief of
the intelligence agencies and also
Ambassador the United States and he we
talked a lot about this about the
history of Palestine they're very Pro
Palestinian but they also are very
sanguin about what the history is and
they understand and bandar goes through
this history that you know the
Palestinians he says you know and this
is what I think people have to
understand because they everybody's made
it this
binary narrative that it's the Israelis
against the Palestinians and really and
and Israel is
therefore guilty of all the things that
are wrong with the with Gaza that Gaza
is a open air prison because Israel made
it an open air prison and nobody
understands the history of Gaza that
Israel you know uh in
2006 2005 handed Gaza not didn't want
Gaza you know they try to give it to the
Egyptians in
73 Egypt wouldn't take it um nobody
complained incidentally when Gaza for 20
years when Gaza was part of Egypt nobody
wanted a Palestinian State then and when
he when um when Chiron gave it
Independence and at that time Shon Paris
said we want to help Gaza we want to
turn it into the Singapore of the
West we will pay Israel will pay to
develop the port of Gaza so that they
can be the greatest port in the
Caribbean they gave Israel donated 3,000
green houses that were state-of-the-art
green houses to make Gaza
self-sufficient in food
Gaza became you know the greatest
recipient of international Aid in of any
people in the world getting more than
any people and instead and the go Hamas
what came in there in
2006 through the you know the
Palestinian Authority people knapped
them and threw them from the roofs and
said we don't want anything from Israel
anything from Israel is dirty and they
smashed all the green houses they
rejected the money for the port they've
taken almost every penny that they've
gotten and they've turned it and and
used it to Bu weapons instead of making
things better for their
people and of course Israel is going to
put up a fence they got they have
they've sent 30,000 rockets and mortars
to Israel since 2006 30,000 there's no
country in the world that would put up
with
that at civilian targets and imagine if
Cuba sent one missile on
Miami how long would it take us before
we occupied the full island it would it
would take two days so um uh they and
you know and then they you know do this
raid I mean we met Americans can't put
even remember what happened to us on
911 we got ahead and we immediately went
over and found the guys who did it in
Tabora and of course Israel has an
absolute right to go into Gaza and they
um and they you know they have a moral
obligation to protect their people like
every country in the world has that
moral obligation it's the number one
moral obligation
now I I hope they won't go into Gaza and
for one for a number of reasons one I am
re I I think it will be a terrible
battle and the more rubbly I think it
will be like Stalin
Grant and as got you know Hamas fight
dirty it likes to put make its civilians
human Shields they're going to have
their Fighters hanging out in the
tunnels the hostages are going to be in
the
tunnels and there's worm holes all over
the place and rabbit holes where they
can come up and fight and it's like
Stalingrad the more Rubble there was the
more e the easier it was for the
resistance to operate so I think a lot
of Israeli kids are going to die in
potentially tens of thousands of
them and um and the the publicity around
the world is going to you know it's
going to amplify all these voices of
anti-Semitism that are happening now all
over the world I think the you know the
the saddest part of this was the um was
the the you know what nyaho did with
allowing $1.5 billion dollar to reach
Hamas which um which really injured the
moral Case for Israel and it makes it
you know it makes it more trickier to
have this pure case which we which I
think we had prior to that um but also I
you know we're on the brink of a nuclear
war we could if because it's it's very
very you know Lebanon could come in
Syria can come in Egypt already has
350,000 troops staged to come in they're
threatening to Turkey CCE is saying that
he's going to come
in and if that happens Russia will
almost certainly come in and we could
easily Sleepwalk into World War II and
you know the United States the people
are running our government now Anthony
blinkin Jake Sullivan ail Haynes uh
Victoria Newan I don't think any of them
have a healthy fear of nuclear war we
also have a diminished Armory and you
know we're fighting a two-front
war and it's going to be tempting to go
to the you know to the punchline to the
end game
because uh you know we we're not the
Israeli Army is not equipped for a very
very big war like it was 10 years ago
they haven't been you know they've been
doing police actions they haven't been
new ring reil
fighting and those Arab countries are
now very very well armed it's not the
same countries that they were fighting
in you know' 67 and 73 and all these
other you know Wars it's a very very
different countries that they're f now
so I'm very worried it I it literally
keeps me up late at night if I were in
the white
house I would be reaching out to pres to
to president X I'd be I would reach out
to
Putin I would reach out to these other
countries and say how do we make this
not turn into a nuclear confrontation
the Russians have a thousand more
nuclear weapons than we do they have
much better nuclear weapons than we do
they have have defensive weapons which
we don't have they can shoot down our
weapons we have a hard time shooting
down
theirs um you know they have a defensive
strategy so they know how to shoot down
our
stuff and um and you know Russia only
has one base around the world it has one
base in Syria China has one and a half
bases and also then you get a
complication if we're frighting this two
front War it's the perfect time for
China to go into Taiwan and we cannot
live without
Taiwan Taiwan makes the microprocessing
trip chips that are necessary for every
smart us weapon every missile has them
every uh all of our Weaponry needs these
uh you know these uh um tsmc microchip
microprocessing trips that are only made
in
Taiwan it's like the oil of the past if
if if China gets a hold of that resource
uh we simply they they will out weapon
us so um and it's a perfect time for
them to go into Taiwan if we're involved
in two front War so I have all these
scenarios going on in my head and
thinking about you know if I had that
job what I would be doing and I don't
think the people now I think the people
who are in that job now are
inept and that it's really scary now I
want to I just want to say one last
thing was is that bandar speech which I
urge you to
read he he talks about the fact that the
this long history going back to you know
um to 1947 into uh you know into the
grand muy of Jerusalem who was working
with you know with Hitler on you know
the final
solution and that in 37 they were
offered a two-state solution 47 they
offered a two-state solution 67 they're
offered a two-state solution and they
they come up with all the Arab countries
come up with the three NOS no peace no
negotiation no
recognition and in 84 they're again
offered a two-state solution and he goes
through in 2001 the tavan Camp David
Accords ahood Barack offers
heartbreaking concessions including all
complete return to the 67
boundaries except for 3% of the West
Bank and giving 3% of Israel
land Iraq didn't do it didn't want to do
it nobody in Israel did Clinton twisted
his arm made him do it but they offered
it to him and yaser
Arafat walks away from that without a
counter offer and
then say five six years later at
Oslo um andor's talking to him and he
goes through he his descriptions of
Arafat are really interesting and
insane and he goes through he goes
through
uh he says to Arafat at that time he
says you know the deal you got at OSA
was not near as good as the deal they
offered you at Camp David in 2001 that
Clinton on his way out
offered and he and arat said that deal
was 10 times better than what we just
signed and um and bandar says why didn't
you take it he said because my own
people would have killed me if I did and
he said that's the
problem at the Palestinian leadership
all talk themselves to the fact that the
only solution is the extermination of
every Jew and the obliteration of Israel
and that is anybody like Hamas in its
Charter says negotiations are fruitless
anybody who engages in them should be
killed it's a treachery to our to Islam
to even negotiate now how do you have a
negotiation partner how does you know
the kids at Harvard what do they think
think that you know what here's what I
always say if you want to stay calm in a
in a this this a good technique for
staying calm if you're an an
argument about
Palestine ask the person what do the
Palestinians
want what do they want they want an
extension of the governments they have
which
are are a parttime
governments that use them right to run
for office in Gaza or West Bank Jews or
Christians Christians and Jews have no
rights in those countries I mean you you
talked about you know brutal aparte
regimes those countries are you know are
are genocidal constrict to their own
populations so what do the Palestinians
want do they want a democracy no there's
never been any Claim by any Palestinian
that we want a democracy they they want
two-state
solution what do they want nobody can
answer that question because the
question the the answer to it is they
want to eliminate every Jew and they
want to obliterate Israel and it's been
the same answer since 1922 1937 1947
it's it's always been consistent is we
own the land Islam the the
Quran makes it an offense against Allah
to give up land that was once conquered
by Islam it was conquered by Islam you
know the ottoman during the Ottoman
Empire and they it's a crime for them to
give it up so you know in
when when Israel was created in 1948
there were 548 th000 Jews in Israel and
there were 390,000
Arabs and the and what the way that they
divided it is they said we're going to
give all the parts of bance at first
they gave most the palestin away to the
Palestinians in trans Jordan and then
they brought in a foreign government the
hashimites to run that so that is the
realthe government you know it's got a
minority running that they did the same
thing in Syria with the alawites it's
alawites running a Palestinian
country nobody cares about that as long
it's not Jews running it then they they
they um you know they uh anyway they
there's no answer to that in every case
the only thing that they've asked for is
uh you know when they gave it away when
they divided up the appeal commission
came in and they interviewed the grand
Muffy and they said can you live with
Jews and he said no he said we'll
exterminate him he he was very Frank
about it so they said the only thing
that we can do is have two states and so
we'll take the parts of Palestine that
are majority Jewish and give those to
the Jews we'll take the parts that are
majority Arab we'll give it to the Arabs
they were both indent the Jews have been
there continuously for 3700 years the
Arabs had mainly arrived in the 20th
century you know with the because they
were attracted by the economic
development of the Jews they were
attracted by the uh by the British oil
industry and that's how mosim Ed there
but they're you know look at their names
they're Egyptian names they're Moroccan
names they're not so they had all arriv
around the same time the same time that
you know the Zionist movement started
but there was a majority of each and
that's how they did it and it was there
and it was the only that's what they did
with the rest of the Ottoman Empire they
said we're going to divide the Ottoman
Empire now that there is no Ottoman
Empire we're going to divide it up to
we're going to give it to the indigenous
people and in in uh in Palestine there
were two groups and they gave it to
him isn't it refreshing hearing a
politician who actually knows history
and dates and reality and
geography you know I always we play
clips of all the politicians on my show
obviously and I always find in the few
moments and I I can get it with you and
I can get it with disantis where it's
like oh there's somebody that's telling
the truth and when you hear the truth
you you you're not contorted you're not
Twisted it's easy to hear the truth and
everything you just said there was true
and unfortunately know with with the
algorithms of Tik Tok and everything
else they've brainwashed a generation
not not to any of that um but what it
was making me think as you were talking
about the history because I don't know
how many people we can win over the
history maybe there's something else we
can win them over with can you talk
about why you think it matters it may
Israel May matter to some of these
people who are Jewish here but why does
it matter for America and Americans
because I also see another version right
now of of sort of the libertarian
version of oh just forget that land
forget all that it has nothing to do
with America I personally see it very
different I'm wondering what you think
about that yeah I mean you know the My
Philosophy with with America is that we
need to unravel the Empire so we have
800 bases abroad we pay 10 times for our
military we pay more for our military
than the next 10 Nations combined
combined oh you know we don't we can we
can cut our military expenditure in half
from from well it's now 1.3 trillion if
you include um if you include the you
know the National Security expenses
usaid and uh and you know the National
Endowment for democracies which I will
my uncle started them I will end them
because they are completely perverted
what they have what they become they
don't do anything good for our country
but I I you know I'm going to cut our
military budget substantially down to
500 billion which is the same that it
was when during the height of the Cold
War on eyes an hour in 61 was in there
and um and we can what we need to do is
arm ourselves to teeth at home we can
protect our borders make ourselves too
expensive to ever invade and then
protect the sea Lanes protect the uh the
neutral areas like the Arctic and make
sure that we have the the resources that
are critical to us including the oil
resources that are critical to the world
that we have a uh strike capacity to
make sure to be able to protect those
and Israel is critical and the reason
it's critical is because it's a bull
workk for us in the mid East it's almost
like having an aircraft car in the mid
East it's our oldest Ally it's been our
Ally for 75
years um it is been an incredible Ally
for us in terms of the technology The
Exchange and you know and building the
iron doome which we've paid a lot for
has also taught us enormously about how
to defend
ourselves at home for missiles so those
military expenditures um are are you
know are are all going 75% of it goes to
us companies are under the agreement
under the
mou but if you look at what's happening
in the mid East now Iran is now um a the
closest allies of Iran are Russia and
China Iran also controls all of
Venezuela's oil esbah is in
Venezuela they have propped up the
Maduro regime and so they control that
oil
supply um bricks Saudi Arabia is now uh
joining bricks so those countries will
control 90% of the oil in our in the
world if Israel
disappears the vacuum in the midd East
which is you know Israel is our
ambassador it's our presence our beach
Ahad in the mid East and it gives us um
it gives us ears and eyes in the mid
East it gives us intelligence gives us
the capacity
to um uh to to to influence Affairs in
the mides if Israel disappeared Russia
and China would be controlling the mid
East and they control 90% of the world's
oil supply and that would be cataclysmic
for US National Security so that's the
answer to you uh why don't we hit one
more topic and then I think we're going
to take a couple questions from you guys
uh you mentioned a little bit in in your
talk about big Tech and you you've been
fighting big Tech as hard as anybody for
for quite some time do you ever feel
that we're we're too deep in it now in
some ways to reverse some of the effect
of the censorship and what we learned
from the Twitter files and the
algorithmic tricks that we know of but
as I always say I'm more worried about
the ones that I don't know of and how
they might be shadowbanning you at this
very moment and how much the the
agencies are still probably entangled
and even Elon has said he thinks he
might have moles still at Twitter even
even now uh do do you really see a way
out of that Jugger out of so ous I I
think we it's very dangerous and you
know what we can't really afford to be
at War right now with Russia and you
know in these kind of conflicts with
China and even
Iran we we need to be sitting down with
each other and figuring out how to
control AI you know and we can't TR we
cannot Chase AI out of this country we
cannot make this a hostile environment
AI because super intelligence is coming
it's
terrifying but we better have it better
here than anybody else if we want to
protect our national security because we
don't we're going to be owned by
somebody else whoever controls that
super intelligence is going to control
the world and Humanity may not be able
to control for
Long we have this kind of TurnKey
totalitarianism that is waiting there in
the wings where if a you know if a bad
dictator took over um you know now they
got AI
GPS that's following you everywhere even
your you know your cell phone is
listening to your conversations and
recording them and knows everything
about you you know I I I was I mean all
of us have this experience I was talking
to my wife that we need a new mattress
and both of us got you know in bed at
night and both of us got three mattress
ads on our phones the next morning so
and it's not just the mattress company
who's listening to you it's the NSA
who's storing all the conversations so
it is terrifying but I think there are
if we get smart people in a room like
Elon there's uh there are
things that we can do to at least
mitigate the um the the intrusive
impacts and the controlling capacity of
this new surveillance technology I you
know I had dinner with Jack dorsy the
other night and I asked him that very
question you know how would he control
it and what he said to me is you need
need to have absolutely transparent
algorithms and we need to give people a
choice about what kind of what their
algorithm is and make it completely
transparent so if you want to if you
want to have a republican algorithm um
you can have that if you want to have a
democratic algorithm you choose it
yourself um if you want to have uh an
algorithm that just is neutral and
produces the you know the most red news
or science news whatever
you choose it and you know what it says
and you know what it's going to do that
makes it much more difficult for it to
um uh for them to manipulate you we're
now all being manipulated we're all
being manipulated by algorithms that we
don't
understand and um and right now the
algorithms have
nefarious um objectives so they have an
agenda you know and the agenda may be
just to keep you interested to keep your
eyeballs on the site that's the least
Sinister agenda but it's very
Sinister CU as we know the way that you
keep people on the site is by
reinforcing their biases and their
prejudices and that you know amplifies
the polarization that is now tearing our
country
apart if you and I are living right next
door to each other and you're a
Republican and I'm a
Democrat we both ask the same question
on Google we're going to get entirely
different results because the Google
algorithm is the is sending us things
that it thinks are going to hold us on
the site and as it turns
out people like reading things that
reinforce their existing prejudices and
their existing biases their existing
worldviews and and so but and
then you've got all these other people
the intelligence agencies who are now
designing the algorithms that are
manipulating us you know and saying you
can't see this information we don't want
you to see see this we want you to
believe this and those things are really
Sinister so the you know what dorsy said
is that the the best solution to that is
to have us able to choose our own
algorithms and that way at least we know
how we're being manipulated we're
manipulating ourselves rather than
having some you know nefarious group
manipulate us and I said that's a
brilliant solution you know why don't
you tell Congress about it and he said
I've testified five times before
Congress and I've said the same thing
every time and it doesn't make a ripple
so anyway if I get in there I'm going to
do that
stuff if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop screaming
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell